right now we're going to take you to
ukraine where shocking new images from a
town near kiev have led the ukrainian
president to accuse russia of genocide
russian troops withdrew from that town
and other communities near the capitol
leaving a trail of destroyed military
hardware but they also left hundreds of
bodies in the streets
leading to global outrage now russia
denies any responsibility for this holly
williams is in southeastern ukraine in
the city of zappo regia holly this is
very tough to watch when you look at the
images of the bodies many of them tied
up with their hands behind the back it's
tough good morning to you
good morning yes russian troops have
withdrawn from around ukraine's capital
kiev but there are no celebrations in
this country because what they have left
behind is sickening and we want to warn
you that our report contains some deeply
disturbing material
in the town of butcher the streets are
littered with bodies in civilian
clothing
some with their hands tied behind their
back appear to have been executed others
are buried in a mass grave more than 300
residents were killed according to the
mayor
in the village of kalininka irina
kostenko says the russians killed her
only son alexi
the pain is so bad she says he was only
27 years old
she says she brought alexi's body back
in a wheelbarrow and buried him by
herself in the garden
wrapped in a rug in a shallow grave
showing a photo of alexi as a child she
says this is my love my sweetheart
on a highway outside kiev ukrainian
officials say these images show the
naked corpses of at least four women
they claim the russians tried to burn
the bodies there have been several
allegations of rape against russian
troops during this invasion ukrainian
officials say they're investigating
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
accused russia of genocide speaking on
face the nation yesterday
we are being destroyed and exterminated
he said and this is happening in the
europe of the 21st century
the city of mauryapol has been besieged
and bombarded by the russians for weeks
thousands may be dead according to the
united nations but the horrors there
can't be countered because mario paul is
cut off
seventeen-year-old ilona and her
ten-year-old brother milan made it out
of the city on friday with their father
we found them sitting silently at an
evacuation center apparently
shell-shocked
there were constant bombing raids
constant explosions
were there times that you thought you
wouldn't make it out alive
yes she said but we tried to hold
ourselves together we tried not to panic
denied killing civilians in butcher
making the extraordinary claim that
these scenes were staged the russian
soldiers who did this will likely never
be brought to justice
despite those images and thousands of
russian soldiers reported killed
vladimir putin's approval rating has
gone up to 83 percent according to a
recent poll but russian media is
restricted in reporting the truth about
what's happening here in ukraine and
many russians rely on state-controlled
news
tony
holly williams with those difficult
images from the front there in ukraine
holly thank you very much the